(bright music)
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- I have to lead with congratulations.
Baby number three, right?
Is on the way?
- Yes, yes.
- That's so exciting.
(audience cheering)
Are you excited or worried
about being outnumbered or--
- It's like sometimes you just
make poor life choices and
you gotta roll with them.
(Kelly laughs)
- And you roll up your sleeves.
- We're insane, we're insane.
- Yeah.
- Can I just show you
something real quick?
- Yes.
- Before we continue,
'cause I'm super proud of it.
- Okay.
- Look at this right here.
(audience cheering)
- Is it two thousand--
- I did that.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Me and eBay.
- Oh my god, I love you and eBay.
- Yeah.
- Oh god.
- It's a women's medium, so it's tight.
- I love it.
I love it.
It'd be snug on me too, brother.
So how did your wife like, let you know?
- Okay, so it was
actually a beautiful day.
Like, I'm eight years sober,
so it was like my sober birthday
and she wrote me a card
and it was to say congratulations.
And she was like--
- First of all, eight years sober.
(clapping)
Yeah.
- I did it all by myself.
- That's incredible.
- No help.
- No help at all.
- Nope. Came in on a winning streak.
- No support.
- Yep.
It's been a joyful
journey the entire time.
- That's awesome, though.
- So she said, "congrats"
and she said, "just so you know,
on your ninth sober anniversary,
you're gonna be a father of three".
And so it was this like
wonderful little revelation
and I was like, I knew it.
You've been acting weird all week.
I knew you were pregnant.
- Women love to hear that.
- Yeah. You've been strange.
- I thought you were moody.
- You've been unusually kind all week.
No.
- She went the other way.
- And then we went to a Diwali party
that night at the White House.
- That's awesome.
- Which I'd never been to the White House.
It was incredible.
We dressed up, we got all gussied up.
They took us through like
four things of security
and it's a Diwali party,
which is Indian New Year.
It's how we celebrate.
- Beautiful.
- Yeah.
Now, Indians like to eat food.
We enjoy eating on Diwali.
- So do Southerners.
- Yeah.
- Just every day, not just like the one.
- Lot of comparisons.
- Yeah.
- Between Texans and Indians.
Yeah.
- Totally.
- Very fine line separating us.
But we get to this Diwali party
and Mr. President speaks
and Kamala Harris speaks
and Jill, president--
- Biden?
- Yes. Jill Biden.
- Doctor--
- Doctor Biden. Yes. Oof.
- Got a lot of titles.
- Yeah, well I should've figured out
what to call 'em before
I sat on this couch.
- [Kelly] I know.
- But there was no food at this party.
- What?
- None.
There were like hors
d'oeuvre, finger food.
So my wife--
- Was it because of
like Covid or something?
- I don't know.
I just think they don't know Indian people
as well as they should at this point.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- But my wife and I,
luckily my mom and dad
live right outside of DC.
They're about 25 minutes
from the White House.
So we came, we saw them
speak, we got dressed up,
we took some pictures and
then we went straight home
and had a full feast at
home with the family.
- Yes. You did it right.
- On Diwali.
Yeah, exactly.
I was like, mom, you gotta do it up.
Let's go.
- Yeah.
- So we had a formal dinner at home,
which was really nice.
- I like that.
Do you get home often?
Do you get back home?
- No, not really as much as I should.
- That's why's special though,
that you were in town
and you got to do that.
That's cool.
- Yeah, my parents love to have me home
and tell me to stay there.
My mom's like,
"There's a room in the basement,
you could just come back in".
(laughs)
- And you can be that guy
living in your mom's basement.
- She's like, "look, this acting thing,
let's be honest, it's not
really working out for you.
You should have been a doctor,
at the very least a PhD".
- Oh my God.
- "Just come to the basement,
there's an en suite bathroom.
You have everything you need".
- You don't wanna be that guy.
Well, speaking of family,
we saw online that y'all
got Guinea pigs recently.
Did you get your kids?
(audience gasps)
Oh my God, your dog gets
along with your Guinea pig?
My dog tried to eat our Guinea
pig when we were little.
- My dog--
- It's traumatic.
- My dog likes to eat
other animal's feces,
so she likes to hang out around.
- That's a dog thing.
- Yo. When we had the cat,
she was all up in the kitty litter box.
- Yeah.
- And now with the Guinea pigs,
she's just straight up
like mouth to the butt.
Just--
(audience chattering)
Like a feeder.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's gross.
- Like a feeder.
- But you know, I love Guinea pigs.
My wife wasn't sure about it.
And what happened was,
my mom, she works at NIH,
National Institutes of
Health in Bethesda, Maryland.
And at the time, this
was like 25 years ago,
they used to do animal experiments.
Like they used to dissect
rats and things like that.
And once upon a time they got
this Guinea pig in the lab
and everyone fell in love with it.
And I showed up and I was like,
"Mom, you can't, please don't
cut this Guinea pig open.
I love this Guinea pig".
- Oh my God. That's traumatic.
- Yeah. I was like, "Please".
And my mother, being the
sweet woman that she is,
stole the Guinea pig from NIH.
(laughs)
She smuggled that (beep)
out in a cardboard box
and picked me up from school
one day and there she was.
And that Guinea pig
lived with us for years,
probably several, you know,
medical issues and things like that.
But--
- Yeah.
- She was there with us for
like four or five years.
So when Tiare, my daughter,
said she wanted Guinea pigs
I was like, we gotta do it.
- So stoked.
- They're a huge part of my childhood.
Emancipating one from
a government facility?
- This is a movie.
- Yeah. Statue of limitations is over,
so, y'all can't do (beep).
Sorry. You can't do anything to my mother.
- Speaking of like the White House,
you brought that up a moment ago
and I was like, when I
went to the White House
I thought the crazy thing was
there's all this security
to get in, right?
But then once you're in,
literally me and my ex like walked around
and we were like, "I
guess we can do this".
Like, we just--
I mean, I'm sure there's
cameras everywhere, obviously,
but we just walked around.
- I stole so--
(laughing)
So many napkins, first of all.
- I didn't steal, but I left something.
- What'd you leave?
- I think it was jade.
It was like, one of the times I went,
I think I left a green
piece of like, jade.
For good luck.
- So cool.
- Just for, yeah.
We need it, right? Like, yeah.
- We think differently.
'Cause I was trying to steal some books.
- Dude, I was like, jade, sage,
I was all the things I was trying to do.
- They have the presidential
china just sitting on a wall.
I'm not gonna take a tea cup?
What? Like, come on
(audience laughing)
What are we doing here?
- What are we doing?
I definitely would've done that.
I feel like--
Yeah, people would've come
down from the ceiling--
- Swarm, swarm. Yeah.
- or something.
But first let's talk about your kids.
You have a three year old, right?
Is he potty trained yet?
Or are you still going through it?
- How old is your son?
- My son's six, we're about to be seven.
And my daughter's about to be nine.
- He--
- Look at that sweater.
- Yeah.
- Style.
- My wife knows how to do it for sure.
- Yeah.
- We're trying to potty train him.
Like, we incentivized by giving him
like Hot Wheels cars
if he uses the toilet.
So he's got like a hundred Hot Wheels cars
and is still dropping like
adult size grenades in diapers.
- Yeah.
- He's very much against that potty.
He's all about--
- It's amazing to how little
they are and what comes out.
- It's astounding.
- It's incredible.
- It's a war crime.
It's really, really, it's messed up.
- [Kelly] I know.
- And then he'll ask me to hold his hands
and he'll be like,
- No.
- "Breathe with me.
Papa. Papa, Papa.
Breathe with me".
- My daughter used to do that.
- "Can you go get mama?"
- My daughter used to be like,
"Can you hold my hands?".
And then she (chuckles).
I don't think we need to be here for this.
- I know, right?
We have to like--
Can you blink?
- [Kelly] Private time.
- Do we have to stare so deeply
into each other's eyes right now?
The only good thing is
only my wife is allowed
to clean the dookies.
Like I'm not allowed to.
- Oh, they won't let--
- So I'll be like,
well, you don't want me.
Sorry. No gagging for me today.
- Yeah. It's a crazy thing being a parent.
Okay. Here is a photo of your daughter.
She's eight, right?
- She's gonna be eight in a week. Yeah.
- She is fabulous
and very Janice Joplin
vibes right now going on.
I like it
- That's her at Comic Con.
Dressed like Sheila Carrasco
who plays Flower in "Ghosts".
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- That's her in cosplay.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- Yeah. Although she would dress like
that on a daily basis, anyways.
- My daughter loves dress up as well.
- She'd be stoked.
- So does my son.
Well, everyone loves "Ghosts".
Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Such a success.
So tell your mom you
didn't need to be a doctor.
- She would disagree with you.
You should take that out.
(Kelly laughs)
That's not gonna go over well with my mom.
- So wait, tell us what's
going on this season.
- Just the ghosts are getting
to know each other better.
There's more interpersonal relationships.
It's a sexier season.
It's edgier.
And then Rose McIver, who plays Sam
and myself, who plays Jay,
we just are sort of in the middle
of this whirlwind of characters.
- Yeah.
- And for me, dude, I just,
honestly, it's like being at home.
I got kids running around that I ignore,
I go to work,
(laughing)
I got ghosts running around that I ignore
and it's pretty much life
and art are imitating
each other at this point.
- Figure it out.
- Yeah. Like, "What do we do?"
I'm like, I don't know.
I'm staring at the wall
pretending you're not here.
That's basically what it is.
And to everyone who watches "Ghosts"
and support us, thanks so much.
It's really like become the people's show
and the amount of--
(audience clapping)
- My music director is the
one that turned me onto it.
Yeah. He loves it. Jason.
- It's just, it's so cool.
I've had a long career of
things that haven't hit.
And things that were a
struggle to get eyes on them.
So to be--
- You know what a blessing it is.
- Yeah. To be a part of something
that's special to people is so deeply,
it's such a blessing.
So thank you everyone.
- Yeah. No, that's awesome.
(audience cheering)
And it's real too,
especially with chemistry
with your co-stars,
like really loving that environment.
That's awesome.
Your co-star actually,
Danielle Pinnock was here
and said that y'all have
intense competitions.
Is it on set?
Do you get into this?
- Not really, 'cause I think
I would win every single one.
- You don't wanna make people feel bad.
- No, no. We are fierce competitors.
- Yeah.
- Everyone from top to bottom.
We have former professional
athletes in the cast,
our directors, our crew,
we have table tennis,
we have a basketball hoop,
we got every kind of board game.
It gets rough.
Like, it's amazing that we stayed close.
- It's amazing y'all get work done
with all those fun things.
- Well, the funny thing about TV
is you spend a lot of time sitting around.
Yeah.
- Yeah. Hurry up and wait.
- So thank God we get along
and thank God those people
are as beautiful as they are.
We really, really do
love each other, yeah.
- I know. I love that, I love that.
When you made it big though,
I have to ask,
you're hitting with "Ghosts",
you're doing all these things.
You got "Sexiest Man Alive".
You got that.
(audience cheering)
It was a sexiest list last year, right?
- [Utkarsh] Yeah.
- Come on now.
- My mom was like, "They
had to pick that picture?".
My mom was like--
- I think every dude I know that gets
in this list was like--
- Look at that guy!
- "Why did they pick that picture?".
- Look, I was like, "Ooh, I'm
here for my library card".
What are we doing?
Yeah. So.
- I love it.
- I'm the sexiest 38 year old,
that came out in like October
and I turned 39 in December.
So I held the crown for
all of like 45 days.
I've given it away.
It was nice while I had it
but I had to abdicate the throne.
It's gone.
- That's awesome though.
- Yeah. It was cool.
- I would show everyone.
- Hey.
Yeah. Oh, I mean, my wife
was very happy about it.
- Yeah.
I'm like, hey, look.
- Look, look. You're welcome.
- She's like, "Well you're 39 now,
so it doesn't even count".
- So, dream is dead.
- Sorry. Yeah.
- So we talked about "Ghosts",
but you also have a new
movie coming out soon, right?
Is it a rap musical?
- Yes.
- Okay. I wanna see it.
- Yeah, it's coming on Disney Plus.
Thanks to everyone at Disney
for helping us make a Disney movie.
It's like a dream come true of mine.
- Yeah.
- It's called "World's Best"
and I wrote it with my friend Jamie King,
and I wrote the music with
my friend Charlie Bethel
and Tommy Kail, who directed Hamilton
is producing it with me.
And it's about a young
boy named Prem Patel.
He's a math whiz, which
doesn't go over very well
at his school.
- Yeah.
- And he finds out that his
dad was a world famous rapper
and his dad has passed away
because I wanted to play a ghost
for once in my fricking life.
- That's cool, yeah.
- And I start to visit this kid
and teach him how to
become the world's best MC.
And through our relationship
and through his relationship he kind of,
it's a coming of age story and it's fun
and sweet and full of music.
And I grew up without having anyone
who looked like me on screen.
And my heroes were from
all different areas
of the world, but I never
saw a South Asian kid
in a lead role.
- Yeah.
- And so for me it was
really important to live out
that childhood dream through
this kid, Manny Magnus
who he found, who's just exceptional.
And plus, I'm too old
to play a 12 year old.
- You tapped out, you are 39.
- No, yeah, I'm 39. I'm dad.
I'm dad now.
I'm ghost dad now.
But we're just so excited
and I can't wait for you
guys to hear the music
and to see the movie.
- I love it.
All right,
well you did a freestyle for
us last time you were here.
- Yeah.
- So would you be willing
to build on that this time?
I don't know, maybe with my band.
(audience cheering)
Would you be--
- Yeah, absolutely.
- We need a topic.
So how about parenthood in
honor of your new little one?
- Yeah, yeah.
- How about parenthood?
- I need you to help me vent, though.
- Okay, I can do this.
- So, okay.
So, I know you have two kids.
- Have two, yeah.
- River Rose?
- And Remy B.
- Yeah.
- And I just want you to tell
me a couple things please.
About both of them, if you don't mind.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- That drive you crazy about them.
- Oh, the things I can say on air.
- [Utkarsh] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, okay.
I'm gonna start with my son.
Cause I need a minute on my daughter.
My son, he never picks anything up.
And my daughter is always surprised,
she's about to be nine, y'all.
Always surprised about having to go
to bed in her own bed for some reason.
Like, and can't get in mine.
- Yeah, love it.
- Yeah.
Get out.
Yeah.
- Do they fight with each other?
- Yes.
But they're also, they're equally buddies
but they're equally enemies.
Yeah, they're frenemies.
Yeah.
- Frenemies.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay.
- But he--
I don't understand.
It's like the plague.
He won't touch it again.
Like it's on the floor.
He already touched it.
He's not gonna touch it and pick it up.
I don't know what that is.
- All right.
I think that might be enough.
- It's a lot, I can tell you.
- Well, I mean I could get more,
but I know this segment has
to be 90 seconds or less.
- Okay, let's walk over to the band.
Let's do it. Okay.
- Let's do it.
(audience cheering)
- Okay.
Okay.
Oh, gimme my mic. Gimme my mic.
What am I doing? 'cause I can't rap.
- Okay, let's do it.
You guys ready?
(upbeat music)
- I'm nervous.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
♪ These are the things I do ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ These are the things I do ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ Hey mama, it's Remy ♪
♪ You look around ♪
♪ All of my (beep) is
all over the ground ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ That's right ♪
♪ You need a little more
wine up in your cup ♪
♪ Cause you better guarantee ♪
♪ That I'm never going pick them up ♪
♪ Hey mama, it's River Rose ♪
♪ Question in my head ♪
♪ Why the hell can I sleep in your bed ♪
- I don't know but get there.
♪ Come on ♪
♪ Let me get up in them sheets ♪
♪ No, no ♪
♪ Please mama, please
mama, I wanna go to sleep ♪
♪ Hell no ♪
♪ These are the things I do ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ These are the things I do ♪
♪ Yeah. ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ It's Remy B, hey ♪
♪ And River Rose, yeah ♪
♪ Remy is dropping and
River's picking her nose ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Kelly knows yeah ♪
♪ Sipping on the vino ♪
♪ Oh, here we go with
The Kelly Clarkson Show ♪
♪ So, so, so these are the things I do ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
to make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ These are the things I do ♪
♪ I do, I do, I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
to make my mama go crazy ♪
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] You are so good.
- That was great.
I'm shaking
- I just love that I said, "no, no".
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- Give it up for Utkarsh
Ambudkar, everybody.
"Ghosts" is Thursdays on CBS
and be on the look out for his new film,
"World's Best" on Disney Plus.